hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his short work
what is our Leo Tolstoy is going to
devote chapter 7 to you might say
disentangling and and if you want to use
the word deconstructing a fusion that
often takes place between words
expressing moral values he thinks that
this is fundamentally mistaken and this
is not as big of an issue in our time
with the three particular words that
he's using but similar things happen
with other value terms as well where
perhaps the cool or the innovative get
translated into the good right and and
there's this blurring of categories that
he wants to resist he thinks that this
happens all the way back in ancient
Greek thoughts about goodness and beauty
and he says that the highest perfection
of the good and not only coincident with
beauty but mainly opposed to it which
the Jews already knew in the time of
Isaiah and which was fully expressed by
Christianity was completely unknown to
the Greeks they thought that the
beautiful must necessarily also
be good this is true the foremost
thinkers Socrates Plato Aristotle sense
that the good might not coincide with
beauty
Socrates expressly subordinated beauty
to the good Plato in order to unite the
two ideas spoke of a spiritual beauty
now you know he's glossing over things
very quickly here we know that that
Socrates is very interested in Tolkien
all right
in beauty and we see that you know if
Plato's symposium is really faithful to
Socrates and if not it's at least
faithful to Plato that we have the form
of the beautiful and we have the form of
the good and they're really the the same
thing there's a lot of distrust of being
seduced by beauty in Plato but there's a
lot of connection between the two as
well
and Aristotle uses toq alone to mean the
nobles right so there's some real
problems with this according to Tolstoy
in ancient Greek reflections on
aesthetics and ethics part of the
problem is they weren't even
distinguishing between those two right
they weren't separate areas of study and
then we have the Christian Middle Ages
which for the most part the aesthetics
of Tolstoy time is ignoring and then we
have as he calls it the the rise of you
know aesthetics in the wake of Bauman
garden if you haven't read balm garden
that's okay he says that here we go it
talks about the the Trinity of good
truth and beauty in the astonishing
theory of bomb garden according to which
it turns out the best that can be done
by the art of peoples who lived eighteen
hundred years of Christian life is to
adopt as its ideal the same one that was
held by a small half-savage slave-owning
/ people 2,000 years ago who portrayed
naked human bodies very well and built
buildings pleasing to the eye and he
says learned men now write long vaporous
treaty son beauty as one member of the
aesthetic Trinity the beautiful the true
that good and he gives us the germ
- una des vara that's Goethe and the
French the bull available with capital
letters right and so what is Tolstoy
complaining about here what is he
resisting here this notion of blurring
these categories together far too easily
and we could say well wait a second -
didn't he read Kant doesn't he know that
Kant is already disentangling these
different areas of value apart from each
other yes that's that's true but Tolstoy
is also criticizing the culture of his
time and he wants to point out to us
that these concepts are as he says in
commensurable with each other so he's
going to strip these apart from each
other and say that art is going to have
to take this discordance into account so
how does he distinguish them he says the
moment we renounce for a time this habit
of regarding this Trinity is having the
truth of the religious Trinity and ask
ourselves what we always understand is
the meaning of the three words of this
we will be convinced beyond doubt how
utterly fantastic is the uniting of
these three utterly different and above
all in commensurable words and concepts
no that's rather high dudgeon there that
he's in isn't it but he is making an
important point there is a non
coincidence between the good the true
the beautiful if there is a coincidence
it would have to be in some sort of
transcendent object not in the world in
which we make artworks and appreciate
our works so what is the good now not
everybody's going to agree with his
concept of the good here but just follow
along and see where he's going with this
he tells us the good is the eternal the
highest aim of our life no matter how we
understand the good our life is nothing
else than a striving towards the good
and then he clarifies that is towards
God so you know he's talking about the
Summum bonum the highest good
the supreme good the one that puts other
things in perspective the one lacking
which we will not be truly content or
happy he's not saying that nothing else
is good but he's saying that this is
really central to the concept of the
good and he tells us that it's a
fundamental concept which metaphysically
constitutes the essence of our
consciousness a concept undefinable by
reason why because this is the concept
which defines not a concept that can be
defined okay so we've got the concept of
the good now and again it doesn't matter
whether we agree or disagree with this
construal of the good we want to see
whether it's going to coincide with the
concept of beauty and the concept of
truth so then he says the beautiful is
nothing other than what is pleasing to
us if we strip away all the other things
that we say about the beautiful what we
mean is something that produces a
favorable impression of pleasure with us
he says so this tells us something the
concept of beauty not only does not
coincide with the good there are two
different concepts but is rather the
opposite of it the good for the most
part coincides with a triumph over our
predilections while beauty is the basis
of all our predilections so beauty often
leads us astray from the good and beauty
is also you know to some degree
seductive into making us think if we're
willing to do this that what is pleasing
to us is therefore good good as such
good so there's a not only non
coincidence but an opposition here that
we have to be concerned about he says
the more that we give ourselves to
beauty the more we are removed from the
good and then he says somebody might
object there's a moral and spiritual
beauty and he says here you're playing
with words what do you mean by moral or
spiritual beauty it's not the same thing
as the beauty of the
landscape or the beauty the you know
very ripe pear that you're holding to
your nose and smelling before you take a
bite out of out of the juicy flesh of it
and taste the sweetness right that's not
what moral or spiritual beauty really is
he says that's actually goodness so
spiritual beauty are the good for the
most part not only does not coincide
with what is usually meant by beauty but
is also the opposite of it so two legs
of the stool or two parts of the Trinity
are now sundered from each other what
about truth so here he says it's less
possible to assign this have oneness
with the good or the beautiful but even
any independent existence at all which
is a rather strong claim so what is
truth according to two Tolstoy here he
has a definition for you correspondence
between manifestation or definition of
an object and its essence or
understanding of the object common to
all people
is this a correspondence theory of truth
it kind of sounds that way because of
the term correspondence but it's between
an object and its essence so that's a
little bit different than say the word
or thought and the you know what we call
the reality that it's referencing so you
know what exactly is his theory of truth
it's a little bit tricky here to explain
but it's not going to coincide with
beauty or truth he tells us first of all
the concepts of beauty and truth are not
only not equal with the good not only
are not of one essence with the good but
do not even coincide with it
so you know that's a problem because he
says truth is the correspondence between
the manifestation essence of the object
it's one means of attaining to the good
but in itself truth is neither the good
nor the beautiful so he says Socrates
and Pascal regarded a knowledge of the
truth of useless objects as disk or
with a good Seneca is another great
example as well and then he says what
about beauty so this is where it gets
really interesting
answered beauty truth has nothing in
common with it and as for the most part
opposed to it why because while exposing
deception truth destroys illusion which
then Tolstoy says is the main condition
of beauty so when you're revealing the
truth of things you are creating
conditions in which it becomes difficult
for things that are pleasant to us that
are beautiful for us to retain that
quality so truth does not coincide with
beauty any more than a coincides with
goodness and what are we left with these
three are fundamentally different
notions and we shouldn't harness them
together and assume that they're going
to lead to each other he says the
arbitrary uniting of these three
incommensurable now notice what he says
next mutually alien mutually foreign
concepts served as the basis for the
astonishing theory according to which
the difference between good arts
conveying good feelings and bad art
conveying wicked feelings was totally
obliterated and one of the lowest
manifestations of art art for mere
pleasure against which all teachers of
mankind of warn people came to be
regarded as the highest art so why was
he carrying out this analysis and
criticism and these distinctions because
he thinks that in his own time and we
might say that our own time has a
similar set of challenges before it as
art became a matter of beauty and
pleasure or we could if we want to
extend it even further and get away from
beauty just say any sort of positive
aesthetic response on our part when that
became the definer of good art
then the danger is if we think that
beauty is the same thing as goodness or
the same thing as truth we will easily
get sucked in and we could use other
aesthetic categories as well the
interesting the creative the uncanny all
of these things that that grip us
they're not there by good just because
that happens and they're not there by
true or revelatory of some deeper
greater truth that's the thing that that
Tolstoy is particularly worried about
and that's why he goes into this
critical analysis
you